I'm going to do a couple of lattice
multiplication examples in this video
and the next one will try to understand
why it worked so let's say we're trying
to multiply 27 times 48 what you do is
you write down your 27 the 2 and the 7
are gonna get separate columns and you
multi-multi your 48 down the right-hand
side and then you draw a lattice this is
why it's called lattice multiplication
so the 2 is going to get its own column
the 7 is going to get its own column the
4 is going to get its own row and the 8
going to get its own row now the fun
thing about lattice multiplication is
you get to do all of your multiplication
at one time and then you can finish up
the problem with all your addition you
don't have to keep switching gears by
carrying and all of that although there
is carrying but it's all while you're
doing in the addition step now we're
almost done with our lattice which you
have to draw these diagonals here we'll
understand in the next video why these
diagonals even work just like that and
now we're ready to multiply 7 times 4 is
28 7 times 4 is equal to 28 so you write
down a 2 and an 8 just like that
2 times 4 2 times 4 is equal to 8 so you
write down a 0 8 just like that then you
have 7 times 8 7 times 8 is equal to 56
so we write down a five and a six and
then finally 2 times 8 2 times 8 is
equal to 16 so you write down a 1 and a
6 just like that and we're done all of
our multiplying now we're ready to add
so what you do is you go down these
these diagonals that I drew here so this
first diagonal which is really the one's
diagonal you just have a 6 sitting here
so you write a 6 just like that then we
move over to the next diagonal this
diagonal with the 6 5 and 8 in it that's
our tens diagonal so 8 plus 5 is 13 13
plus 6 is 19 so you write your 9 right
here in the tens place and now you carry
the 1 and 19 up there into the hundreds
place because this is just 19 it's
actually 1
290th 1910s anyway you carry your 1 you
have 1 plus 2 is 3 3 plus 8 is 11 11
plus 1 is 12 you write the 2 in your
hundreds place and you carry the 1 into
your thousands place 1 plus 0 is 1 so
you just have a 1 in your thousands
place just like that and you get our
answer
27 times 48 is equal to one thousand two
hundred and ninety-six 1296 let's do a
harder problem one that requires more
digits just to show that this will work
for any problem let's say we had five
thousand four hundred and seventy nine
times this to a three-digit number times
787 so just like we did in the last time
we make four columns one for the five
the for the seven and the nine we'll
have a five thousand four hundred and
seventy nine and then times 787 so they
each get their own row 787 so like that
then we have to draw our lattice draw
the lattice each of these guys get their
own column draw the columns just like
that
and then each of these characters get
their own row one row for the seven one
row for the eight and one row for this
other seven then we have to draw the
diagonals draw like that one diagonal
two diagonals three diagonals or
diagonals I think you get the idea and
then we have just one two more diagonals
we're ready to multiply now so it's nine
times seven I won't do it on the side
here we know our times tables 9 times 7
is 63 7 times 7 is 49 4 times 7
is twenty eight five times seven is
thirty-five let me switch colors
arbitrarily 9 times 8 is 72 7 times 8 is
56 4 times 8 is 32 5 times 8 is 40 I'll
switch colors again 9 times 7 we saw
that before it's 63 7 times 7 is 49 4
times 7 is 28 and then 5 times 7 is 35
we're done all of our multiplying now we
can switch our brains into addition mode
we find a nice suitable color for
addition maybe no maybe a pink will do
or addition so we started our ones place
just have a three there so you write the
3 in your ones place your the tens place
2 plus 6 is 8 8 plus 9 is 17 write the 7
in the tens place carry the 1 into the
hundreds place now I wrote a 1 really
small here 1 plus 3 is 4 4 plus 7 is 11
11 plus 6 is 17 17 plus 4 is 21 21 plus
8 is 29 right the 9 in the hundreds
place and carry the 2 2 plus 6 is 8 8
plus 9 is 17 17 plus 5 is 22 22 plus 2
is 24 24 plus 2 is 26 26 plus 5 is 30 1
is 31 carry the 3 3 plus 4 is 7 7 plus 8
is 15 15 plus 3 is 18 18 plus 0 is 18 18
plus 3 is 21 right the 1 carry the 2 2
plus 2 is 4 4 plus 5 is 9 9 plus 4 is 13
right the 3 carry the 1 1 plus 3 is 4
and weird
one that easy I think well there's two
advantages here one is we got to do all
of our multiplication at once and then
we've got to do all of our addition at
once the other advantage is it's kind of
neat and clean when you just do it this
the traditional way with carrying and
number of places it takes up a lot a lot
of space but notice we did our whole
problem in a nice neat and clean area
like then we got our answer our answer
is four million three hundred and eleven
thousand nine hundred and seventy-three
there you go
now in the next video we're going to
understand why this worked